- So, what's up, Jamie?
- Ted Lasso.
- Oh, he's really gotten
up your bum, hasn't he?
- He's not even a real coach.
- So, without further ado, the new manager
of AFC Richmond... Ted Lasso.
- Ted is a small-time American
football coach,
gets hired to coach
a professional soccer team in the UK.
- Jesus.
- He doesn't know the rules
of football when he comes here,
but our favorite version
of an American character
is ignorant
with curiosity.
- Why don't we just jump right in?
Anybody got any questions?
Oh, yeah.
No, should've saw that coming.
- For a TV show
about football,
which is obviously
very male-dominated,
we have two super-strong
female characters.
- What is it you do again?
- I'm sort of famous for being
almost famous.
- Maybe think of it as Plan B.
- Rebecca and Keeley, I think,
when you first meet them,
are very different women,
who you might think might not get along,
and actually become
extraordinarily wonderful friends.
- It made me think of you.
It's strong and a bit prickly.
- It's really funny, and it's
sort of secretly a little bit deep.
But don't
tell anyone I said that.
- I think people
will fall in love with Ted,
and I think they'll like
the message that he's bringing,
which is you don't necessarily
have to be an expert in everything,
you don't have to pretend
you're something you're not.
You can just be you,
and you can be a success
by being kind
and gracious and thoughtful.
- How do you feel?
- Yeah, just-- Dunno, there's
so many new feelings. All right, yeah.
- Kind of like getting
your first pube, right?
- Yeah-- What?
- Even if it's written in a way
where there's pure humor in it,
Ted is somebody
that would expand your mind
when you don't
realize it's happening.
- All the characters
who come across Ted
are changed by him
in an amazing, heart-warming way.
- I have a real tricky time hearing folks
who don't believe in themselves,
so I'm gonna ask you real quick again:
Do you think this idea will work?
- Yeah, I do.
- Whoa!
Why are you screaming at us,
Nate? We're right here.
- It's a genuinely funny show,
and if you've got 30 to 40 minutes,
you're not gonna
regret watching it.
- I don't think I can get away
with that anymore.
- Sure, you could.
Fashion's all about confidence.
You know,
if I didn't have any confidence,
I never would've
worn pajamas to my prom,
and ended up in jail
the rest of that night,
but you don't want to hear that story,
so I ain't gonna tell it.